señor crespo si el valor de la moneda no
cambia más allá de la facilidad de hacer
cuentas en que ayuda a esta reconversión
y la definitiva hoy los venezolanos
vimos que se concretó la muerte del
bolívar soberano una moneda que fue
destruida en los últimos tres años
apenas ahorita el media agosto y va a
cumplir este tres años valga la
redundancia esa moneda y que bueno es el
producto del proceso de hiperinflación
que atraviesa el país por más de tres
años
el mismo fue pulverizado el anuncio de
la eliminación de 60 en el bolívar
en la nueva moneda es una medida
fundamentalmente cosmética es un
maquillaje que sustrae 60 sal bolívar y
que en definitiva es el único beneficio
que tendría es que va a facilitar las
operaciones contables las operaciones
administrativas en los sistemas de las
empresas y las instituciones que estaban
colapsada producto de la cantidad de
cero exacerbados que se estaban
generando en las operaciones por una
moneda depreciada unam una edad esté
pulverizada por el proceso de
hiperinflación que hemos tenido muy
agudo en los años en los últimos años en
venezuela
en el bolívar se soberano en una moneda
altamente repudiada y que no éste no
cumplía con las cualidades que se
esperan tenga una moneda como
característica y esta decisión en que a
fecha realmente a la vida del ciudadano
venezolano si la moneda que se usa a
diario es más bien el dólar
como tú bien lo dice desde el 2019 en
venezuela este viene ocurriendo la
presencia de la dolarización
transaccional es desordenada es
importante dejar claro que no es una
política este del gobierno fue un hecho
que ocurrió este impuesto
fundamentalmente por las empresas y la
familia ante el rechazo por el bolívar
soberano largar a los sectores
económicos comenzaron a utilizar el
dólar como medio de cambio este y como
medio de referencia y el bolívar fue
asumiendo fundamentalmente un papel muy
mínimo transaccional para que utilizamos
en día los venezolanos el bolívar para
el menudeo y para operaciones muy
pequeñas de más de 67 por ciento de las
transacciones se vienen realizando en
dólares este el valor referencial los
precios se expresan en dólares y este en
definitiva como obesidad anteriormente
es una decisión que lo que busca es
resolver los problemas contables y
administrativos que se han generado en
las operaciones de las empresas
instituciones financieras en el país
dado el colapso del bolívar soberano y
muy brevemente le pregunto si el país
está encaminado a la recuperación
económica como lo asegura el banco
central de venezuela
experimentando es importante aclarar que
el anuncio de una nueva moneda no viene
acompañado de un plan económico no hay
ningún anuncio que este oriente sobre la
resolución de los problemas
macroeconómicos del país continuó no hay
una orientación de un viraje en la
política monetaria y la política fiscal
por lo tanto consideramos que el país es
mantendrá a los desequilibrios
macroeconómicos que ha venido
presentando que la dolarización
transaccional permitió la recuperación
de algunas actividades comerciales y
este bueno se observa el repunte en las
actividades terciarias de la economía
nacional